joined by the minister of state at the
ministry of justice victoria atkins it's
great to see you thanks for joining us
on the program this morning quick
thought on the gdp figures before we go
any further 0.8
slowing growth from 1.3 in the previous
quarter we had the fastest growth in the
g7 last year we've got this slowing now
but we're back on track uh 24 25 will be
right back up to the fastest rate of
growth and that was very much the um
the
point of the queen's speech was to say
look we've got to really help our
economy grow over the coming years and
the queen's speech is going to set the
legislative framework to enable that to
happen
okay um to that end um one of your mps
lee anderson making headlines this
morning um here's what he said in the
comments yesterday
there's not this dude this this massive
use for food banks in this country we've
got generation after generation who
cannot cook properly they can't cook a
meal from scratch they cannot budget the
challenge is there do you agree with
them
i i think when i was watching lee in the
chamber i think he was talking about his
own local food bank and how the food
bank was trying to offer not just
immediate help with provision of food
but also longer-term help for example
help with budgeting and so on and i've
got community groups in my constituency
the alford hub that really tries to wrap
their arms around people and look after
them and help to address
the various aspects that may be causing
difficulties so look i
absolutely believe that if volunteers
people working on the ground can find
ways of offering longer term support as
well as the immediate help of a food
bank then of course they should do that
this is the front page of the mirror
this morning i mean this is how it will
be interpreted throughout the country do
you agree with him tori's the poor can't
cook
absolutely that's how it's coming across
i know and and as i say
having watched the debate i'm not sure
that was actually what lee was saying
and i'm you know when we look at the
work of the government we have tried not
just to give immediate help uh with
issues such as energy
costs we know that energy costs are
really fueling great great worries great
problems for people as indeed they are
around the world but also trying to
offer longer term solutions so for
example um you'll remember the debate
over free school meals during the
holidays
and we are spending something like 200
million pounds on holiday activity
programs in schools this is the point
where you say this is where the point
where you say you don't agree with him
that was a ridiculous uh crass thing for
him to say and he needs to apologize
yeah inferno so i have said i don't
agree with him and he needs to apologize
well i think i mean lee is very
articulate he will um i'm sure make
himself clear i think he's doing a bit
of media today but i i this is not the
view of me or anyone else in government
we want to give not just immediate help
but longer term support as well
and i you know i really really
appreciate the efforts of food banks and
voluntary groups around the country who
work day in day out to help people when
they are in great distress do you
condemn what you said
i do i mean look i do not agree with it
i do uh that headline as i said i'm not
sure that headline really reflects okay
let's say let's listen again to what
he's saying
again the whole debate let's listen
again to what you said there's not this
use this this massive use for food banks
in this country we've got generation
after generation who cannot cook
properly they can't cook a meal from
scratch they cannot budget the challenge
is there
so in as i say i watched the
full uh debate you know the full section
of the debate and he was talking about
his local food bank clearly i do not
agree with that headline on the mirror
clearly um the
need for food banks if people need that
help they must please seek it
and i think you know
he was basically saying people want to
go to a food bank to get a ready meal
because they can't be bothered cooking
yeah no that and that's not right that
is absolutely not right we know that's
not right you know i've spent my
ministerial career working uh with very
vulnerable people i i do you know the
complexities as to how people and
uh end up in situations that they feel
very very uh distressed about as a
constituency mp i see it and
cooking lessons will not be the complete
solution 250 of course not 250 000 homes
are going to fall into destitution
destitution next year and you have an mp
a tory mp saying something like that
hardly surprising that people think that
this government's out of touch well as a
that's not in fairness that does not
reflect uh the work of the government i
mean if you look at the very immediate
work that we have done
uh already this month or last month to
help with the cost of living crisis
including the council tax rebate that
happened last month we have raised the
national living wage to help the poorest
and the lowest paid of people and in
july we will be raising the national
insurance threshold which means that
people keep more of their hard-earned
cash so these are all measures that
we're bringing in we've
doubled the household support fund this
is a fund that local councils administer
to help the most vulnerable and the
neediest in their local communities
we've said that a third of that must be
helping pensioners because we are very
very aware of the distress that people
are in at the moment and we want to help
them and yet 250 000 people homes not
just people homes are going to fall into
destitution what a word um that is what
we could do is have a windfall tax which
would raise uh about two billion pounds
we also i think need to help people
understand where when there is help
available so we know there are something
like 850 000 households that aren't
claiming pension credits to which they
are entitled so getting the message out
to people to seek help where they can
there's a really good website called
moneyhelper.org.uk where people can get
free advice trusted advice as to what's
available can't afford electricity to
power up their computers but there are
help lines out there to if they're able
to and and so you know that this is
there is a program as i say of work
across government to help people who are
independent full tax where are we with
the windfall to find we're having to
find both immediate and longer terms
okay when full time on the windfall tax
i mean uh we
look we
the chancellor has said we will look at
measures um throughout this process uh
and i think as a government we have
shown during the pandemic that we will
absolutely change and
work on policies that uh as issues arise
i'm not involved in those discussions
that may be happening in treasury but
what we've tried to set out in the queen
speech it's a framework for really
growing our economy so you're not ruling
it out
well as i'm not involved in those
conversations but the chancellor in
furnace has said that he will continue
to review this and he's also challenged
energy companies that um if they're you
know they need to show very clearly
their investment plans over the coming
years for this country because of course
it's not we're going off detention there
we're going off to detention and we only
have it we only have a limited amount of
time minister as you know next month
it's about the coming year something
that you will have a view on given that
ui i think i'm writing saying a former
lawyer barrister barrister forgive me um
as far as uh the northern ireland
protocol is concerned we're hearing that
the attorney general is going to be able
to prove that it won't be um illegal to
uh scrap the northern ireland protocol
um if that is the case is that something
that you would support
well the i haven't seen the advice uh
and of course the the attorneys will be
seeking legal advice on matters of such
significance as this um i think as with
the rest of government my primary
concern are the people of northern
ireland they're part of our country
they're our friends our neighbours our
relatives
and we know that the protocol at the
moment
is not only creating political
instability because we need to get the
executive up and running that is proving
very very difficult but it is also um
providing problems for people in their
day-to-day lives so rising prices
shortage of goods and so on um i'm
convinced that we will be able to find a
solution to this because i'm sure that
the eu
will listen to our arguments but i think
it's right that we say look we have got
to review this to see how it's working
but it wasn't something that was
fostered on us it was it was this prime
minister's idea yeah and we entered
those negotiations in good faith but
after now several months many months uh
it is having this impact in northern
ireland and you we know it was a bad
deal when he did it even though he told
us it was a good deal he was done it was
absolutely negotiated in good faith but
we have to be realistic about the
political situation in northern ireland
we want to get that executive up and
running
and we need to ensure that the good
friday agreement is absolutely protected
because that piece is so very precious
so it's not westminster that's at fault
it's the northern ireland politicians
that so far i'm not saying anyone's
watching it at the moment i'm so exactly
as i've said kay that um there is a
difficult political situation in
northern ireland that we want to resolve
well we have an executive that you know
we are unable at the moment there's not
an executive no and so we need to ensure
that we can try and help uh local
politicians set that executive up so
that northern ireland can continue to we
were told it was an oven-ready deal
we were told it was an oven-ready
island's health um yeah absolutely and
look we entered that negotiation in good
faith and i'm sure and you did a deal in
good faith that's what the eu would say
i'm an optimist and i'm sure that we
will be able to uh come to common ground
and find a solution with the european
union so you don't feel it was
international it was um it was an
international treaty but not legally
binding is that what we're saying well
we are in the middle of it at the moment
so um
article 16 is is in the agreement for a
reason that if there are problems then
the parties can look at uh how to try to
address those problems we've been
working on this i mean we
set out the command paper i think last
summer setting out our concerns about
this unfortunately some of the things
that the eu has suggested we think um
don't help the situation we think they
take us backwards so for example uh to
send a birthday present to northern
ireland under these plans apparently one
would have to complete 50 fields of a
customs declaration you know this
they're part of the united kingdom we
just want to try to find a solution one
wonders why he didn't think about that
beforehand before i let you go with
we're almost out of time but um i want
you to talk to me about your brief if
you would uh quickly in the
cross-examination
of video recording yeah so um we have
been working now for a year on trying to
improve not just the uh
convictions of
rapists people accused of rape but also
importantly the
treatment of victims within the criminal
justice system so we're taking a
forensic look at every single stage and
one of the measures that we're
announcing today is that we are rolling
out even further
pre-recorded evidence for victims of
rape and sexual assault so that they can
give evidence on a video recording much
much sooner after the attack and that
recording is then played in due course
at the jury trial and we're trying to do
this because we know one of the reasons
um that we are seeing the uh the
rates of conviction being so low is that
victims get to the stage where they
simply can't support the prosecution
anymore we do not want that to happen we
want to support them and so this is one
of the measures that we're trying to see
if that will make a have an improvement
in the system okay we are out of time it
just pops into my head slightly out of
left field but levi bellfield i don't
know if you've seen yeah should it be
allowed to get married absolutely
appalling i've um ordered an immediate
review into this uh when it came to
light last night i i just to reassure
people i understand an application has
been made that has not been decided yet
and he most certainly has not yet
married but if i may he's got the right
under article 12 of the european
convention and the human rights act to
get married or so they have the right to
have the application considered by
prison governors uh and i think i'm very
much welcome the debate we're about to
have about the bill of rights and
looking at human rights for in the
united kingdom in the 21st century and
believe you may i'll be raising this